[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll tell you how
cloud data loss prevention can help you
detect and protect sensitive data across
your systems
cloud data loss prevention or cloud dlp
is a fully managed service that lets you
discover classify and protect all kinds
of sensitive data from various sources
cloud dlp can recognize up to 150
different data types like names
addresses dates credit card numbers and
more
you can even define your own custom info
types based on custom dictionary
detectors or regular expressions
every sensitive value that dlp finds is
assigned a certainty score ranging from
very unlikely to very likely giving you
the flexibility to set a confidence
threshold for inspections and
de-identification jobs
speaking of the identification the cloud
dlp api offers a number of
de-identification techniques to obscure
mask tokenize or transform those
sensitive values in your data based on
the info type and the likelihood score
with cloud dlp you can send data
directly into the api or schedule
inspection jobs that will scan the data
that you specify for sensitive values so
you can regularly gain visibility into
the data that you store and process
cloud dlp has built-in support for
scanning and classifying data from cloud
storage and bigquery and has a streaming
content api and hybrid api so that you
can scan other data sources or so you
can use it as part of custom workloads
and applications
the api even leverages optical character
recognition to scan images for sensitive
data allowing you to detect and redact
that data from image files
so next time you're looking to detect
classify and secure your sensitive data
take a minute to look at cloud data loss
prevention to learn more check out
cloud.google.com dlp
[Music]